représenter mon pays faire la fierté des
Ivoiriens bah c'est un rêve du gosse
hein kelci aime le jeu en Angleterre
avoir l'ambiance tout et c'est KCI
supporte là-bas donc partir là-bas je
veux être un grand club mais on do
commencer tout en bas
[Musique]
d'abord ça c'est les premiers exercices
de de statique
tout
[Musique]
ça la méthode jeanmc Guillou c'est
simple c'est recruter les les les
enfants dans dans dans le bon âge hein
vraiment 12 13 ans
la sélection est drastique comme comme
vous ditite on prend généralement un
joueur sur
1000 donc on est très très exigeant donc
on doit avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
joueurs pour pour en recruter si ou si
ou 7
[Musique]
quoi
si on leur met des chaussures des
chaussettes des protèges tibia c'est
c'est comme si tu vas faire un footing
avec un sac au dos de de 5 kg quoi donc
on enlève ça c'est une contrainte en
moins ils sont plus légers donc ils
peuvent s'entraîner plus après ça
beaucoup d'avantages tu développes un
meilleur toucher de
balle tu développes de meilleurs appuis
jouer pied nu c'est de la micro
proprioception en permanence il y a
moins de blessure le le jeu va plus vite
[Musique]
salut
salut c'est la côteivoire qui
[Musique]
gagne rentrer le ballon à l'opposé bien
sûr
[Musique]
j'ai obtenu les ch au bout de 2 ans 3
ans par là parce que céta vraiment
difficile avec le
soleil 15 fait beaucoup chaud donc
quand on a fait fteve si vous avez le 3è
degré vous avez les Ch AZ droit à une P
de 20000 vous n'z pas
encore donc c'est un pe un
privilège sur la ligne àim reprends
reprendsend la lig com sur la
ligne ah secour
2093 nous on était les
premiers donc on a commencé les pieds n
fux et à mesure bah progressivement on a
fait tout ce que tout ce que ces gamin
là font aujourd'hui c'était on était
comme une famille il nous a inculté les
valeurs l'amour du jeu l'amour du foot
la philosophie gimg et aujourd'hui je
suis chanceux d'être parmi ces
éducateurs là pour apprendre à nos
petits frères aussi de de pouvoir rêver
aussi
[Musique]
tout le monde m'appelle maman la maman
de la CAD ah j'occupe enfin la place des
mamans des enfants puisqu'ils ne sont
pas avec leur maman et tout ce qu'une
maman peut faire je gère pour eux
de
je coup don à l'Académie parce que ma
maman n'est pas là elle donne à manger
elle
représente mal so a besoin de quelque
chose dem
je voudrais bien que tous réussi bien
que je sais que c'est pas eux tous mais
je voudrais qu'il soit à haut niveau à
haut niveau c'est mon
souit